>> Jesse: IT'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST LIBERAL MEDIA
EMBARRASSMENTS EVER,
MICHAEL AVENATTI IS SENT TO THE
SLAMMER FOR TWO AND A HALF YEARS
FOR TRYING TO EXTORT NIKE.
THEY HEAVED ENDLESS PRAISE ON
MICHAEL AVENATTI WHO TURNED OUT
TO BE A TOTAL FRAUD.
>> HE'S OUT THERE SAVING THE
COUNTRY.
>> HE'S A ROCK STAR, I THINK.
>> MICHAEL AVENATTI IS A BEAST.
>> YOU ARE LIKE THE HOLY SPIRIT
COME AT ALL PLACES AT ALL TIMES.
>> YOU HAVE TO GUESS AT HAND,
HIS NAME IS MICHAEL AVENATTI.
HERE IS SOMETHING ELSE,
MICHAEL AVENATTI, I WOULD LIKE
TO MEET YOU SOMETIME OVER A
DINNER.
>> YOU GOT LUCKY TONIGHT, WE ARE
BACK WITH ATTORNEY
MICHAEL AVENATTI.
HE IS A MAIN PLAYER.
>> ONE REASON I'M TAKING YOU
SERIOUSLY AS A CONTENDER IN 2020
IS BECAUSE OF YOUR PRESENCE ON
CABLE NEWS.
>> Jesse: THE HOLY SPIRIT,
GREG.
>> Greg: HOW IRONIC THAT SHE
IS A GHOST ING NOW.
SHE WAS SEDUCED BY ALL HIS NEW,
FAMOUS FRIENDS AND BY THE WAY,
THEY ARE ALL HACKS, THEY ARE ALL
WORMS.
DAGEN SAID YESTERDAY, THE REASON
IT WORKS IS BECAUSE THEY ARE ALL
THE SAME THING.
HE'S A SOCIAL CLIMBER AND ALL OF
THOSE PEOPLE WITH MAYBE THE
EXCEPTION OF RACHEL MADDOW ARE
SOCIAL CLIMBERS.
THEY WANT TO IMPRESS THEIR PEERS
IN THE INDUSTRY.
THEY WANTED TO BE NEAR HIM
BECAUSE HE WAS GETTING A LOT OF
THE SPOTLIGHT SO THEY WANTED TO
HANG AROUND WITH HIM.
IN 2024 WHEN HE IS OUT HE CAN
IMMEDIATELY ENTER THE CNN
LINEUP.
I'M PRETTY SURE BY THEN
DON LEMON WILL BE GONE.
BRIAN STELTER OR ANNA NAVARRO
SHOULD SHOW UP TO JAIL WITH A
PIE WITH A FILE IN IT SO THEY
CAN SPRING THIS POOR GUY, BUT I
LOVE THIS TOO MUCH.
I WON'T SAY ANYTHING ELSE
BECAUSE I'M TALKING ABOUT IT ON
MY SHOW TONIGHT, SO SHUT UP.
>> Jesse: I WAS PUT OFF BY THE
FACT THAT THE HOSTS WERE SUCKING
UP TO A GUEST.
THAT SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN.
IT SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN THAT WAY.
>> Dana: UNLESS WE ARE GUESTS
ON GREG'S SHOW, THEN IT IS
ALLOWED.
I'M FOR THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM THAT FOUND HIM GUILTY,
HE'S BEEN CONVICTED, HE'S BEEN
SENTENCED AND HE WILL GO TO JAIL
AND HE'S FACING TWO OTHER BIG
PROBLEMS, SO LOW, THE SYSTEM
WORKS, THE MEDIA DID NOT.
>> Jesse: THIS WAS ONE AND
MANY TIMES THE MEDIA LATCHED
THEIR WAGONS TO A FRAUD.
REMEMBER JUST A SMALL AD, THEY
LATCHED ONTO HIM AND IT BLEW UP
RIGHT IN THEIR
FACE.
>> Greg: HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Jesse: CRICKET.
>> Greg: I DID SAY THAT!
>> Jesse: WHY DO YOU GUYS KEEP
GETTING DUPED, JESSICA?
>> Jessica: IT TURNED INTO A
TOP LIBERAL MEDIA'S GREW UP
THERE BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE THERE
ARE SO MANY BUT I KNEW THERE
WOULD BE MANY MENTIONED AT THIS
TABLE, NOT THAT THAT IS
NECESSARILY WHAT I THINK ABOUT
IT.
I NEVER LIKED MICHAEL AVENATTI
AND I'M NOT JUST SAYING THAT.
YOU CAN CHECK ALL THE TAPES.
WHOEVER THINKS THAT THEY CAN
EXTORT NIKE IS REALLY DUMB.
>> Jesse: YOU'VE GOT TO GO
AFTER NEW BALANCE.
UNLESS YOU ARE --
>> Greg: THEY WILL CALL YOU
RACIST IF YOU DON'T GIVE THEM
MONEY.
IT DAGEN?
>> Dagen: WHAT EXEMPLIFIES
THIS MAN STUPIDITY IS BASED ON
THE OTHER TWO TRIALS HE HAD
ALREADY ALLEGEDLY STOLEN MONEY
FROM HIS CLIENTS YEARS BEFORE HE
STARTED DOING HIS COLUMN ON CNN
AND NBC INCLUDING FROM A
MENTALLY ILL PARAPLEGIC MAN,
ALLEGEDLY, BUT I HEARD SOMEONE
EARLIER IN THE DAY SAYING ON TV,
A GIANT COME DOWN FOR THE ONCE
FAMOUS LAWYER AND I THOUGHT, IS
PRESENT REALLY WORSE THAN BEING
ON BRIAN STELTER'S SHOW?
>> Jesse: PROBABLY NOT AS GOOD
FOOD.
>> Dana: I HEARD A HEADLINE,
HOPEFULLY FROM SOMEONE ELSE,
FALL FROM GRACE.
>> Greg: THERE WAS NO GRACE.
IF YOU THINK WE ARE OVERDOING IT
ON THIS YOU CAN'T LET THE MEDIA
FORGET ABOUT AVENATTI.
YOU CAN'T LET HIM DISAPPEAR.
WHENEVER THEY DO SOMETHING
WRONG, THEY RUN SCREAMING FROM
IT AND THEY NEVER GET THEIR
COMEUPPANCE.
WE HAVE TO REMIND THEM.
>> Dana: AND REMEMBER
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
HE'S NOT BEING CONVICTED FOR
THAT BUT THAT WAS OUTRAGEOUS